here we are in a yellow submarine and
welcome to this video um your part let's
do this and now I'm actually obliged to
play be five in this position I can I
can go d6 first young I can now be five
confusing my own lines so well this is
this is nice for this is nice for me I
think take here and now 9555 not here
right I can also play Bishop a six in
this position that's not not a bigger
issue let's do it my plate that it Ted
quickly i hope i'm not blundering stuff
like 95 or something but it doesn't seem
to work there were you five you know
unless he has a tactic it's really not a
very great great idea i believe so i'd
like to get night here to d3 495
Bishop c5 I think I might want to just
take on your form then after off to d3
just blocking a five want to be sure
that it's not happening then Queenie 7
and 93 okay h5 Queen f7 should be okay
or queen g7 maybe Queen g7 is better
not really attacking me too but I want
to make sure that be three or before is
not coming let's sort of is generally
useful to put the rock down I will at
one point probably be able to take be to
what is threatened be too mmm yeah yeah
but then be three is coming okay queen
at five maybe
Joe looks okay I guess don't see any
particularly threatening thing happening
to me
I have a decent decent pieces night on
d7 and on c5 there a little bit Wow okay
at least him his log think led to
something out of the ordinary now I have
to wait I really have to hide might be a
good firm that's interesting so now i
have 96 here maybe your rookie aid okay
let's do it 496 okay now i can take on
g4 take on e5 I'm not really believing
this 96 now we'll trade some stuff on 94
is that better 96 i think is good check
now i can treat now I'm a porn up
one point of Knight f6 while the threat
had to tend to that rope th is a threat
here setting up an awkward pin now
probably you will click an age 26 anyway
nice taking a long time out okay so
we'll just drop the eight to trade it
come on keep it simple check thank you
for 95 95 is okay I rather want to go to
d2 may be roped you for now this is also
not so bad oh I didn't think about this
move why it's kind of kind of stupid
okay
again trying for this active approach
here and form I wonder will nighty to
even look looked into a scanner
interesting okay now I don't need any of
that just take them after the rogue
traders notice entirely paralyzed so
Roxy to me completely try to dominate
that note you know it is dominated so
let's see how to do this skinny form
time mornin I can check me on before
yeah that's not really doing that much
okay please stop doing it so I'm going
to go for that pin I just have to put
the night to e3 now and his check is
it's over King there there there it's
not really doing that much check but
does it really check check so stalemate
white resides okay so let's check this
f5 was a pretty pretty
aggressive decision really not sure
about it are in position i think i think
it's roughly equal also i mean equal in
an unbalanced way it just is interesting
because the engine gives me an edge but
now i wasn't sure if I've I really have
my doubts that this is working now
engine wants to play 93 yes but this is
not so bad yeah you should have taken on
c5 here this kind of thing this s is
equal by the comp yeah probably and this
is something not working at all chan
here he just has this position with her
with a pawn down for for no compensation
whatsoever yeah gaining gaining time and
gaining space at he is lost yeah so he
probably has to take on c5 or just avoid
the f5 move all together look at the end
it wants to play something like this now
this is somewhat this is nice for black
home why it's the computer giving equal
here I don't understand why is this
equal
a ver que les 94-94 possibly books is
seven and so probably equal it's right
okay thanks for watching